bonjour je m'appelle Christine schillais
je représente un club sur le département
de La Réunion depuis un an maintenant
qui s'appelle l'invitation le club
existe en métropole depuis trois ans le
concept est de créer des partenariats
avec des établissements hôteliers
restaurateurs loisirs bien-être et par
la suite de pouvoir faire bénéficier de
ces offres aux membres donc qui ont la
carte l'invitation alors la carte
l'invitation elle est valable 12 mois de
datadat elle est nominative et
l'avantage c'est qu'elle est valable
dans les DOM-TOM et en France
métropolitaine le petit plus c'est que
le concept se développe aussi en
Belgique au Luxembourg et bien ton
Espagne ce qui permettra d'avoir un côté
international donc à mon niveau ce
serait de relancer un tout petit peu
comme je dis à mon niveau
l'économie touristique je suis
dans la phase de création d'un site
local qui mettra donc en avant ces
établissements
un petit livret qui mettra aussi en
avant donc sur un support papier nos
partenaires et vraiment de diffuser un
maximum le concept l'invitation alors la
grosse différence c'est qu'avec une
seule carte je peux voyager partout et
je peux bénéficier d'offres en acheter à
nous faire c'est le principe
avec les différents concurrents je ne
pense pas que ce soit le cas je sais que
si je vais en métropole demain dans tel
ou telle région je regarde sur leur site
internet le site internet qui est
national
voilà je réserve auprès d'un hôtel ou
d'un restaurant c'est le petit plus je
pense de du concept de l'invitation